it has never been tested and I know
all right we are on Louis it's the first
town hall for members of 2016 in the
last town hall for members before the
primary election start I see that we
have already a pact list of questions
here we have Louis more than ready to go
we have Matt helping us out today three
ways for you to ask questions number one
if you have a camera you can request to
go on screen I believe it's called Matt
will talk to you and you can tell him
what the question is and you know the
entire thing etc etc if you have a
microphone but no camera you can also
ask a question via audio and then third
you'll see down below this has changed
since the last time we did this you can
ask questions via text and the new thing
is that people can actually upvote and
downvote specific questions as it stands
right now the top of Oded question is
not a question it seems to be a request
which is fine but in any case you can
upvote downvote ask tax questions and
we'll sort of take those I wonder Louis
if we should have a thing where we will
take the text questions in the order of
most upvotes I mean does that seem
reasonable to you to sort of instant
voting on what questions to answer I
think we can use that as like a rough
guideline yeah all right okay well I
figured maybe you had more to say than
just that but that's that's what we'll
do then okay so let's let's just jump
into this thing Louis if we have someone
who is ready to go on screen Matt give
us the first candidate please please
proceed governor all right we have yeah
feat a fee joining us so far it's a
black screen ah and there she is believe
this is Alison right okay good I'll
by all means [ __ ] we'll take a question
number one okay okay um well obviously
I've been messaging a lot about this
issue I'm very concerned about realizing
anti-semitism in the world um I think
every day there's just more we're seeing
more and more a lot of this is also
coming at the same time that there's
this record all right well rising
anti-semitism coming at the same time as
something else before Alison got cut off
there so Allison the last we heard was
that the anti-semitism was rising at the
same time as something else what that's
something else as as the refugee crisis
and what we're also seeing is that many
on the left are not taking note of the
rising anti-semitism and instead the
narrative that they're really pushing is
rising Islamophobia and it's interesting
that this is all happening at the same
time so I wanted to know what were your
thoughts on this whole issue of rising
anti-semitism vs zombie phobia and this
whole crisis in the Middle East and all
right very good question so Lewis I
think there are sort of two approaches
to this one approach would be to
indicate that there is sort of some
causal relationship between rising
anti-semitism and a focus on rising
Islamophobia the other approach and I'm
curious Lewis which one resonates more
with you is there's just always disdain
for jews jews have been kicked out of
just about every part of this planet so
there's going to be anti-semitism
correlating but absolutely anything that
goes on more Islamophobia and
anti-semitism less Islamophobia and
anti-semitism what do you think I don't
know if there's a causation thing with
the with the immigration crisis and and
what's happening with Islam and
Islamophobia I think you know I I know
that there are many
Jews that are leaving many parts of
Europe are they leaving because there's
been a rising anti-semitism or as they
become an even smaller minority in parts
of Europe are they persecuted even more
because usually it's the smallest
minorities that tend to be persecuted
the most wherever wherever you are so
you know I i I'm not sure I haven't
really thought too much about that
relationship but I would say that it is
not a causal relationship I tend to
agree I think that just we just we
always have been seeing anti-semitism it
manifests in different ways and right
now we are dealing with simultaneously a
problem of radical Islam and a problem
of Islamophobia and I think that there
are certainly ways in which it's
connected to anti-semitism but
anti-semitism has been quite a constant
for a while as i'm sure many in our
audience know Alison thank you so much
for the question I really appreciate it
alright so I think then we are ready for
the next question if there is one ready
to go on screen and if not we can start
with text questions jboss Jay I think
you you were on with with us last time
right I recognize you all right you have
the floor sir well the question was you
know you'll move to Boston had some
problems in the beginning that I hope
you're all settled and how's austin is
going well i would say that we are
probably about what would you say Louis
ninety to ninety-five percent ready to
call the studio complete and film a
studio tour is that safe to say I think
so yeah it's it's about yeah nine ninety
ninety ninety-five percent is good i
mean there's a few tweaks we want to
make there are a few things that are not
ideal but as far as production goes
we're in a pretty good place and things
are running very smooth inc one of the
biggest areas of opportunity right now
is well there's a couple I'll just why
not Louis I'll just mention a couple of
things that may change over the next
month
a few months number one is we're still
toying with the idea of getting rid of
like the big radio microphones and going
with a lapel mounted mic and a few
people have mentioned that they really
like the look of the big radio mic other
people say they would like to see
something more TV friendly a small mike
that doesn't block us as much I'm sort
of mixed on it I agree that the optics
of the lapel mic could be good but we've
been doing some testing over the last
week Louis and the sound is just not as
good with the lapel mics you know
especially when you have you know we
plan to have more people in the studio
that's something that well I'm sure you
already noticed we have been dixon in a
couple of times and yeah i mean i kind
of like the look of those old mics and
it just kind of gives it that old radio
feel which I just kind of dig and so
technically I think probably not much
more just going to change any any follow
up there Jay thank you all right no you
know thank you all I'm just enjoying the
show right thanks so much always great
to see Jay and we'll keep plowing
through here so Matt if we have the next
audience question here we have a
question which is a comment top voted
loved the Reza a salon piece more of
that please tomorrow we have our next
long-form piece actually it is a
two-parter but we're going to do both
parts tomorrow actually back-to-back it
is on debunking immigration myths and I
think people will really like it so
thank you so much that question coming
from Connie and we will continue is it a
video question is it an audio question
John greenlee john green me says has
lewis ever performed publicly with a
band does he compose music well he
performs something on the bonus show
sometime louis i'll let you handle that
all right I did perform in well in the
band i was with dave a couple in
abandoned dave was in with me in a
couple times that was a very long time
ago but I was in a metal band for many
years I played more shows than I can
count we played many many shows over
something like three years at least
while I was with the band I wrote much
of the music and I think it might be fun
to tune up to play a little something on
the bonus show maybe but the thing is I
mean you know i'm i'm kind of a full
band kind of guy I don't even own an
acoustic guitar but if people are really
interested in they haven't heard my
music before I mean I could certainly
have sense of links and I do plan on
being a performer again in the future I
would like to be in a band it's just
it's tough it's not easy especially when
you're as picky as me about about your
music and about who you're playing with
so I don't know about playing live on
the bonus show but if you want certainly
set send me an email and i can get you
all sorts of links to music I've it will
be good Lewis's after this thing is done
you could tweet out a couple of links to
things you play on just for people who
want to check it out and you're on
twitter at louis MO tommy of course yep
I could do that I think that's perfectly
a reasonable request Dave it might scare
you though this is iris in a very very
heavy dent so you know make sure you
turn the volume down a bit don't want to
hangar your neighbors or family members
all right thank you so much John will
take the next question let's see who or
what pops up it is Dan Burke Dan wearing
a headset I'm sure we will both be able
to hear him and he will be able to hear
us really well because that looks like a
good headset go ahead Dan
hey good afternoon you guys David what
made you get into doing this are do you
want to end up on TV doing a newscast
someday or I find it incredibly
ambitious that you started your own show
and stuff and my teenage daughter and I
look at you and we go I show her and I
go look you can do that too right I mean
you know the big thing is we we are on
TV right we have been on directv and
dish network monday through thursday for
several years now the big I don't know
if we've made this announcement Louis
but we are going to be picked up for the
fifth show Friday's on free speech TV as
well and you know yeah I mean when we
think of if MSNBC showed up at our door
which is highly unlikely but let's say
they did what would that look like and
would we do it the bigger the show grows
lewis especially with the support of the
membership program the less that that
becomes an obvious win because whatever
additional exposure there would be and
increasingly we are getting the traffic
on between the youtube and the podcast
and TV and radio we are getting the
traffic daily of one of the afternoon
hours of MSNBC news so that's all really
good the benefit louis may be outweighed
by the fact that we would ultimately
lose a lot of control over the show and
that's an area yep we we talked about
this a little bit not too long ago and
we we discussed how gent yogurt what
happened when he went MSNBC and he
didn't last long he did not like the
fact that he was told that he couldn't
say certain things about obama i think
was the gist of it Wow but he no longer
had control over what he was saying and
so losing your independence i think is
kind of a scary thing I I would like to
remain independent I think it's it's
been working so i can assure you louis
if we get a blood on by MSNBC you're
going to have to wear shoes in the
studio and i know that's like a big big
thing that you're not really interested
we could we could write something into
the contract i don't think that's
necessary alright well thank you yo and
and the entire thing always a pleasure
to work with people who get the
questions out in a clear and concise way
because that is not a guarantee we have
found out
Louis if you've ever checked our
voicemail line in the morning who knows
what kind of phones people are using
sometimes all right next question from
that we will we will put it up and
Bryant how about bringing in a woman to
balance things out I like that Mick's on
Sam seeders show right yeah I have not I
was just emailing with Sam a few minutes
ago and one of the things we have not
discussed is how the new staffing is
going on his show but all options are on
the table Louis I have nothing to
announce today but let's say that we are
very actively exploring who the next
voice will be participating in the david
pakman show and we are very much aware
of what voices might add diversity to
the mix I mean am I being diplomatic
enough okay I think you're being
diplomatic yeah I think it is a good
idea but it's a matter of finding the
right person it's that's really not easy
to do first you have to find someone who
is in our area who also happens to have
experience on camera that we can look to
and and say oh yeah they're really good
and they have to know what they're
talking about and they probably have to
jog with us I mean if the chemistry is
bad then I don't think anybody wins and
so it it is a very good idea and I'm all
about it and you know well we have hours
early in order to work in an environment
with Louis they would need to be highly
comfortable with quinoa shoes off in the
studio and regular stories about
abortive dating escapades and that is
not everybody is comfortable with that
you know uh well maybe just dealing with
me not wearing shoes I think would be
the big one all right great question
from an always great to hear from her
longtime member and Bryant next question
is from Frank McEvoy and going from
memory alone I believe Frank is checking
in from the DC area but if I had to say
for sure I believe he is in Virginia I
don't
remember exactly where in Virginia
believe it starts with an F although the
exact name is escaping me frank says
what is the most difficult interview
you've conducted for the record you're a
lot nicer to some than I would be the
most difficult interviews are not the
most contentious ones the most difficult
interviews are the one where the guest
is just not interesting and it's very
very difficult to create something
that's even remotely compelling and
we've talked about this before Lewis the
contentious guests you can sort of
prepare for an adversarial interview and
the adversarial nature of it sort of
makes it good often in and of its own
the times where we booked a guest
because the topic is great and the guest
is not that well prepared that for me is
the toughest thing like how do you make
someone interesting yeah I always go
back to have one of those orly taitz
interview or something where she's just
going on and on it seems like she's got
a staff of papers in front of her and
she's reading you know court motions
it's like it was just a nightmare and
that you know that's it's difficult to
to make that an interesting interview
but I mean would you say that may be
interviewing then Senate candidate
Elizabeth Warren maybe was a difficult
interview because there you have someone
who's in full campaign mode and has you
know an answer for every question you're
going to ask predetermined that's why I
got interviewed that many elected
officials and candidates because it's
basically a talking point coma for the
duration of the interview the Elizabeth
Lauren interview was difficult not not
only because she was in full campaign
mode but it was also really difficult
because there was someone standing
behind her just off-camera visibly
displeased at the questions I was asking
later told me that the questions I asked
weren't the questions we agreed to which
I completely rejected we never even
provide a list of questions I provide a
list of topics and then I write the
questions very shortly beforehand and
also sort of like pointing at her watch
and doing all sorts of histrionic stuck
right behind Elizabeth Warren that was
like logistically very very difficult I
know you remember that not to mention
Louis there was like a tracker some
Republican dude who was following her
around with a camera
you want Lewis almost had to physically
remove the dude I was a big dude um yeah
it was quite a scene so I think
politicians I mean in some way the
politician thing is the same as what we
were talking about before where you know
you're not going to get anything that
great and exciting out of them but but
yeah certainly the adversarial ones just
by their nature I mean that's that's a
good start great question from Frank
McAvoy checking in from Virginia i
believe next question coming up is from
larry connelly we have no video or audio
yet from larry there he is the man the
myth the legend Larry Conley second time
that he is participating in one of these
town halls Larry how are you at least
pretty pretty good though you go the
answer today actually it's more of a
comment since I'm a little bit older
than the two of you this year's
Democratic primaries remind me of when I
was a college student in 1968 it was
Eugene McCarthy against Lyndon Johnson a
little bit different but almost the same
in McCarthy couldn't hold out Bobby
Kennedy and got into the race and that
knocked him out but we did not Johnson
out I don't know what Sanders is going
to do about Clinton he can knock her out
and out yeah I mean I don't know that I
even used the term of knocking Clinton
out because at this point yes Hillary is
still favored slightly to somewhat
significantly in the national polls this
it is quickly becoming sort of a
state-by-state game we have Iowa a week
from today what happens in Iowa it seems
like Bernie Sanders is going to get
close to fifteen percent of the vote so
then it's not a question of knock out
its we basically have a tie going into
New Hampshire the following week we get
into New Hampshire every poll right now
that i've looked at says that bernie
sanders is either slightly ahead or
significantly ahead in New Hampshire so
we can come out of this thing the Bernie
Sanders with somewhere between 48 and
fifty-five percent of the delegates of
the boat so far so
I'm not sure I understand the language
of what is it that Bernie Sanders has to
do because he is not the presume not
runner but we have a real race on our
hands here Louis I think so yeah Bernie
there's just so much information coming
at us I don't know what methods
pollsters are using but I think they're
trying to get juicy headlines and and
nice titles but yeah I I don't feel
comfortable saying I know what's going
to happen I just would like Bernie to do
well but I in a way I'm kind of glad we
have a race it's like watching a good
football game you know you want it to be
a close game even if it's your team
because if it's a blowout it's just kind
of boring so I think we'll have wildly
depending on whether you know the
candidates get more agitated we may even
see some chronic traumatic
encephalopathy result from the primary
race as well and that that would
certainly be new Thank You Larry thank
you so much all right next question
today comes from Dylan ciao who says
tell us more about the aborted dating
escapades I mean it was mostly a joke
right i mean Lewis I'm sure if you
wanted to tell stories you could but
that mostly I was just kidding yeah it
was a joke re there was one of those in
when I was in Texas where I went out on
a date with someone that I assumed it
was very liberal and it became clear
very quickly but she was the exact
opposite and you know it was too late
things spiraled out of control not
really out of control it just that was
that it pretty much ended as soon as
that revelation hit the table and I
think that was the last time I had what
Dave might refer to as an abortive
dating escapade so it was gentlemen yeah
Dylan hopefully that is satisfactory
next question coming in is from who is
it from hmm will it be
ready when you are Matt hmm I tech geek
probably not the real name there how
many members watch vs just listen to the
audio podcast the audio podcast has
significantly more traffic than the
commercial free audio of the commercial
free video rather of the show Louis I
don't remember the proportion offhand
but yet more people more members are
listening and I think a lot of you know
people tell me they put it on their
phone for the gym or for rides or
whatever so the YouTube channel does
much better on the public side than the
public podcast but among our members
Louis we have more interest in the audio
member stuff than the video
interestingly enough well it's easier I
mean Dave's more in tune with what's
happening in that world than i am but it
is much easier I mean you get it on your
mp3 player your device you know you have
the podcast programs everything is
download automatically you're listening
in the car you're listening one year
you're jogging you're commuting to work
whatever I get that and so maybe that
has a lot to do with it because I
certainly have plenty of friends who
when they're driving to work or certain
points during the day when there's
downtime that's what they do and I
started getting into that when I was
traveling listening to podcast for the
first time not too long ago and it's
great so of course I don't listen to our
show but yeah there's a lot of reasons I
was in a while when I'm at the gym i use
the stitcher app and i have a bunch of
10 or 12 podcast that it automatically
downloads a new episodes of and every
once in a while i'll say you know i
should really just see what it's like as
an end user to check out our show and
usually I find something like the volume
levels of the brakes relative to the
content are not quite right or something
and then we can sort of workshop it so
every once in a while I do sort of try
to listen on different devices to see
what's going on obviously we see the
view tube videos all the time because
we're constantly checking this or
checking that or looking for a comment
so it's good to every once in a while
listen in myself
to the podcast that's the question from
I tech geek we will take the next
question it is from Paul McGuinness Paul
says if your only choice for the
Democratic nominee we're past failed
nominees specifically Mondale Dukakis
gore or Kerry who would it be this is
tough for me not because I think these
are bad options but because these are
really good options I mean these are all
good options in the interest Louis of
picking someone here it is it is really
very tough i think michael dukakis we've
had him on the show really would have
been a fantastic option i mean just such
a smart guy not that the other three are
not i think that you really couldn't
have gone to a stray with Michael
Dukakis although of course no question
that as we go back in time what was
considered progressive then might seem
slightly sort of traditional
conservative today but I mean look at
look at Al Gore we would not have been
in the mess in Iraq the almost never
ending engagement in Iraq had it not
been for Al Gore not becoming president
I think there's a pretty good case to
make for all four of these guys well I
guess if you are if you're thinking
about those past elections the choices
are pretty obvious but if you were to
say these are the nominees right now and
who do you pick I think for me it would
have to be gore based solely on his
environmental activism and and and what
you would do in that department because
you know what what good is it having a
strong economy if you know if all your
forests are on fire and you know your
coastal cities are flooded and you're
breathing in poison um you know that's
something that I feel very strongly
about so for me it would be gore and
Carrie Carrie of course would be the
most part with that and I will mention
two of those four people have been
guests on the David Pakman show no note
no missed opportunities to mention that
great question from Paul Lewis says gore
I think I say Dukakis but I could be I
could be certainly suede suede otherwise
all four very very qualified candidates
we will continue next question whenever
Matt determines that we have it it is
from Mike Bell if Trump doesn't win the
primary and decides to run as a
third-party should Bernie also run as an
independent candidate assuming he also
doesn't get the primary nomination no
absolutely not if Donald Trump runs as a
third party that would be absolutely
fantastic we've been hoping for that for
months and the positive effect of that I
mean that could single-handedly give the
election to the eventual Democratic
nominee if Bernie Sanders then decided
to also run as a third-party you would
have an effective four-way race it would
be very very risky I know 11 the there's
a group of people who say hey if he's
the best candidate he should run and
whatever boats he's able to get those
are the votes he deserves to get
whatever the results are I think that
the risk is so high right now because
every candidate on the Republican side
is pretty not some less so than others
and in Kasich and Rand Paul maybe chris
Christie or Marco Rubio on some issues a
little bit less crazy but the risk right
now especially with the number of
Supreme Court justices that the next
president may appoint I wouldn't play
any game Bernie should get everything he
can out of the primary I I would love it
if Bernie Sanders was the nominee if he
is not though he should not uh it would
be a gift if Trump ran as a third-party
candidate and it would not be good for
Bernie Sanders to do the same well don't
you think that might depend on how the
primaries go let's say he's not the
nominee but it was by a hair that he
lost I mean in that case don't you think
that he still might be able to win if
the random so because if he ran as an
independent he would basically split the
progressive vote and you would have who
knows what happening on the Republican
side I mean it's just it's hugely that's
not so serving chocolate sauce that's
assuming Trump is running as an
independent yes that's what we're that's
what Mike Bell wants us to assume yeah
so given the scenario i would say do not
take the risk it's crazy I hope Trump
does run as an independent though that
would be an absolute gift no question
about it let's continue tonight on the
January 26 Town Hall the next question
is
from who is it from Michael Morgan many
conflates fossil fuels and all
hydrocarbons as one in the same and how
unlikely it is that these byproducts are
is easily replaced with renewables the
average consumer could actually afford
or be willing to pay the full price for
any future discussion on the ubiquity of
petroleum byproducts and the cost of
replacing these basic materials were we
bold enough to attempt leaving fossil
fuels in the ground well this comes to
an issue of government subsidies I mean
right now petroleum products are
drastically subsidized if we were to
there's no doubt that be full price as
Michael is suggesting of many non
petroleum fuel sources would be higher
or it would be higher per unit of energy
given reduced efficiency etc why would
not the government subsidized those
alternative non petroleum-based energy
sources if we were seeing that now we
would have a drastically different
energy picture so i think what michael
is saying is absolutely spot on this is
the same type of conversation we have to
have when we say oh what if we get all
cars to be electrical where does the
electricity come from it's sort of these
layer to discussions about getting off
of fossil fuels they're absolutely
important but I think they're there are
answers and solutions there yeah but you
know it's the system is pretty stacked
right now in favor of the big oil
companies that energy status quo and I
don't see that changing until these
resources actually start becoming scarce
so you know I was a big am still a big
fan of nuclear a huge fan but it seems
that the American people have abandoned
that so what do you do I think we're I
think we're stuck in in an oily quagmire
sad reality presented by Lewis great
question Michael and will continue to
address it on the show next question I
am told is a video question it is from
ulti dude not sure if that's a first
name or a last name but
I'm glad to have you here and I would
love to take a question nope he is gone
I don't know what happened there uh
interesting interesting I don't know
what happened there alright let's let's
get another text question while he's
fixing that mr. Natalie Davis how would
you convince those who insist they would
never vote for the anointed candidate
support her if she god forbid wind
manama nation I try to talk about the
Supreme Court and they are not moved you
are loved by GDP our listeners in
Nashville right it's Natalie Davis from
one of our affiliates in Nashville GDP
are this is a good question it's a
pragmatic question I mean there are
people who certainly are progressive or
liberal call it what you will they like
Bernie Sanders or maybe they don't but
what they know is they don't like
Hillary Clinton maybe because of
personality issues maybe because she's
not nearly as progressive as they are uh
this is for me a very very simple
conversation Lewis and if it doesn't
resonate with people it's really tough
because it should if you are progressive
you are one hundred percent justified in
saying Hillary is just not that
progressive and i would rather Bernie
Sanders or whoever else that is to the
left of Hillary Clinton consider the
risk to this country if Donald Trump or
Ted Cruz or Marco Rubio or whoever on
the Republican side gets elected there
is no option on the Republican side that
is better than Hillary Clinton and I
tend to look at Ted Kennedy's sort of
political approach the late great Ted
Kennedy the incremental approach it's
not productive to say throw everything
away if it's not perfect and we'll
rebuild in four or eight years if
Hillary Clinton is the best option
remaining on November whatever the day
is I don't know what what date is
election day this year then then we
should vote for Hillary Clinton and of
course there's a consideration for
whether you are in a swing state or not
if you're talking to people in
Massachusetts about whether they're
going to vote for Hillary Clinton or the
eventual Republican nominee it doesn't
really matter that much right Louis
because Massachusetts is solidly blue
when it comes to presidential elections
in swing states it is a param
importance not to allow a lunatic
Republican in the White House yeah who
will do the least amount of damage it's
if if you were going to vote for Bernie
I don't see how you could pick any one
in the Republican field over Hillary so
I'm no fan certainly I'm no fan but her
qualifications are pretty incredible
from a foreign relations standpoint you
know she's been there she's done that
she's got that going for her and
certainly showed you a lot less harm
than someone like Cruz or Trump your
roomie I think then there's not a fan at
all no no it's like the south park
episode Dave when you have to choose
between as they say a douche units or
Santa is very very appropriate analogy
for tonight Thank You Natalie and thanks
to GDP our love that you guys are
running the david pakman show Matt let's
see the next one alguns alguns 22 is the
name of this individual what's up with
the new theme music what prompted to
change well it had been so long Louis
since we changed the theme music and the
new theme music has been the source of
much controversy and we the way it
happened was we were sort of thinking
about new music for the show when we
changed the introduction to the show
which I hope some people have seen and
some other show elements and Kurt
Washington longtime viewer longtime
member came to me and said hey I have
this music I don't know if you there's
anything useful here I listened to it
was definitely different it's not at all
like anything we've had before and we
decided to give it a shot and we now
have a few different oh is out alguns is
on now nope now he's up we had a few we
had a few different songs included
initially we had some people saying I
don't know if this is the right thing or
maybe it is but overwhelmingly Lewis it
seems it has grown on a lot of people i
know some people still don't like it but
it is certainly grown on me and we've
received more and more positive comments
about it
yep I am it's just good to switch things
up now and then i'm sure people noticed
it just started this week than your
introduction to the show the video one
maybe you haven't seen it if you only
listen to you know to the podcast but
there have been a bunch of little little
updates like that and they're going to
be a few more I was thinking about
putting some heavy music music that is
more you know my speed on on the bonus
show I think I would get a kick out of
that I don't know I don't know if anyone
who's listening to me right now would
but something I wanted to every six
pyramid with just thrown is good to be
changing evolving you know trying out
different things and that's what we're
doing right now so Thank You alguns for
the question and we are continuing now
with Tim smirkin how is the search going
for a replacement host on days when you
are not available to host well I think I
don't want to over or under state what's
going on the search is in progress there
are conversations happening and I don't
know Louis what else we really want to
say it can is it fair to say it is one
of our current top priorities it's it's
a huge priority because well because the
show basically cannot operate right now
if either one of us is is sick I mean
Dave Dave could do the show it would
just be a huge hassle and not an ideal
situation so yeah it's definitely a
priority but it's not the easiest I mean
to do basically it's sort of like hiring
I was speaking with someone yesterday
about this hiring and casting
simultaneously so you're looking at
someone in the way you would for hiring
them for a job based on experience and
technical proficiency and skills but
you're also looking at someone for do
they have experience in front of a
camera are they comfortable in front of
a camera do they have a sensibility for
progressive values and ideas etc so Tim
I assure you this has my top priority i
am personally overseeing
this investigation and hope to have more
news for people soon okay let's look at
the next question it is from Dillon chow
what were some of your favorite music
releases of 2015 and what releases are
you looking forward to in 2016 wow I
mean Louis you know my I don't listen to
that much new music when I do I'm
listening to it on Sirius radio I
usually listen to channel 2 3 4 8 9 34
and 36 those are like my main channels
and so I honestly couldn't even tell you
what music I listen to that was
specifically released in 2015 i'm not
sure i know you're big on the new justin
bieber album right um I uh I have one
very good answer that I can think about
the top of my head right now and my
favorite album of 2015 has turned into
one of my favorite albums period and
that is the Anthropocene extinction by
cattle decapitation and it's actually a
band that I believe is made up of all
vegans and a lot of their material is
about that type of thing this album the
cover is is kind of a spin on that
famous picture of the bird that's dead
and they cut open its belly and it's
full of plastic and it's about pollution
it's about you know what's happening in
the world in that realm and it's so
brutal it's it's incredible but I'm huge
metal head and I most people would
probably not like that what am I looking
forward to in 2016 new rotting christ
yeah I don't live in it really offer
great and new ihsan ihsan is formerly of
Emperor he has a solo career and his
stuff is a very progressive metal a lot
of interesting stuff happening there and
so that's why i right I wish I had
something better but I follow the music
scene only sort of tangentially the last
concert I went to well actually I went
to a concert last month Louis went to
matisyahu show in providence rhode
island and the concert before that was I
don't even
member i mean i turn on spotify and sort
of put it on random and let it go so no
good answer from from me on this one
unfortunately Dylan ok let's continue
next question is from Craig what is the
your reaction to the recent news that
Obama will have a private meeting with
Sanders in the Oval Office is it routine
or might he be asking him to hold back
in some way Louis I admit this is the
first time hearing of it I should take a
look at this and it's something we'll
probably want to discuss on the show
tomorrow in fact I'll make a note of
that now I have no idea whatsoever what
the circumstances of the meeting are but
I'm instantly very interested in finding
out more uh yeah it's uh maybe no one
knows maybe all we know is that the
meeting is happening it's probably only
one of two things as I suspect they are
not discussing things that are happening
in Vermont um so my guess is that either
yes he's going to ask Bernie to hold
back or maybe he's preparing to throw
his support behind Bernie that would be
a pretty highly doubt that this is a
precursor to an endorsement at least not
anytime soon I think that there's
certainly a possibility that there is
some strategic element to the meeting
but I I don't know i mean just knowing
nothing else whatsoever i would think
it's more likely that president obama
would endorse Hillary Clinton over
Bernie Sanders if he were to make an
early endorsement but he may well just
wait until the Democratic primary
resolves itself and then support the
eventual Democratic nominee but we will
talk about that tomorrow that is a very
very interesting news for sure alright
let's continue with the next question it
is from Alex ehrenfeld I watch you and
tyt consistently it seems like you and
genk agree on pretty much everything
except for the issue of the regressive
left you think there's any daylight
between tdps and tyt regarding this
issue now daylight between means
difference of opinion right because if
there if you had the same opinion there
would be no daylight seeping through
between
to it my understanding that right when
it is there any daylight between does
that mean any point of agreement or any
point of disagreement um well it seems
like it's something that we disagree on
or at least something that we broach
that maybe they don't so okay so trying
to put daylight between is two separate
things especially oneself from someone
or something else disadvantages yeah I
you know I don't watch that many other
shows I admit I the most the most recent
time i watched Genk do anything was when
i spoke to him at a conference in Las
Vegas a few months ago so I'm not
exactly up to speed on what it is that
their position is currently on the
so-called aggressive left I mean as i
said on dave rubin show recently if you
didn't see that appearance you should
check it out I'm not in love with the
term regressive left I mean the idea of
the term regressive left coined by Majid
Nawaz is the idea that someone claiming
to be a liberal supports a liberal
principles and I think it's definitely a
problem and we've talked about that
extensively to the extent that there's
disagreement with Genk on that I mean I
think like alex is saying we are we are
generally on the same page about people
can disagree we may have lost Louis
there for a second what's your sense of
this louis i mean i think that yet we
don't agree with any show a hundred
percent at a time there's no doubt about
that uh yeah you know that's true i I
know that this is not the first we've
heard of this I see on youtube comments
all the time people are pointing out
that this is something Jake doesn't talk
about or or some people will go as far
to call Jake part of the regressive left
and kind of in the same campus day if
we're we're pretty occupied with the
show we're doing and I don't really
watch much and you know what I'm doing
prep work for the show I'm not really
watching other shows
that's not where I really gather
material so I can't really speak too
much about that but I know many of our
listeners that's exactly what they're
saying they're bringing this up yeah you
know what more can I say engines
building a little bit and I see it in
the comments I'll look at our comments
and there's people saying tyt and you
guys are the only ones that are right on
this or the other version is you guys
are way off on this tyt is right on this
or the other version is I'm so glad you
guys are right on this because tyt is
way off on this and the exact same thing
happens if you look at the comments for
sam cedar and the young turks and kyle
kolinsky on secular talk whoever else
right i mean benjamin Dixon all the
different people so I don't really know
I mean I think there are if you imagine
a sort of Venn diagram there are
combinations of people that agree and
disagree with sort of every two and
three way grouping of programs right now
it's so complicated to keep up with to
be honest that we've just got to keep
focused on doing our show but yes I to
answer the question from Alex directly
it seems as though they are bigger on
people like Reza aztlán over on the
young turks than we are for sure to sort
of put it lightly let's continue with
questions here about 45 minutes in Heidi
Williams says as a healthcare
professional I really do have a question
whether or not Sarah Palin is clinically
insane there's a saying in emergency
psychiatric care but the first thing you
have to do is figure out if the person
is on something they shouldn't be or not
taking something they should be do you
think that she is a on some kind of
substance be mentally ill c acting or
playing a part or d a mixture I think
it's d a mixture I have no idea whether
she is on some kind of substance or
whether she should be and isn't I think
I mean who knows people all over the
world take all sorts of medication for
different things Abby is she mentally
ill yeah I'm not a I'm not a mental
health professional but my complete
layman's understanding of her over the
last eight years at this point is that
there is definitely a screw loose I mean
something is definitely not right with
the woman
think that she very well may be playing
up certain elements of her character no
question about that so i would go with
dee luis some mixture of what heidi is
suggesting i guess so i never really
thought about the substance aspect of it
I think she's someone who is in over her
head that being said you know she did
hold that position in Alaska for some
time and I do people like thirds thanks
for coming well a lot of people like the
things she did even some liberals have
said to me that she did some pretty
great things for Alaska but since the
vice since she was nominated as a vice
presidential candidate she was in way
over her head and I don't know I think
maybe she could use some lorazepam or
something when she's speaking publicly
to kind of bring her down down back to
earth a little bit I think that might be
a good idea well you're the health care
professional do you agree with me no no
I think Heidi is the best to qualified
to speak on that over us certainly very
very good question from Heidi a very
serious question from Heidi no question
about that Matt we will take the next
question when you have it who is next
always a mystery next is Jared since
both of you live in Massachusetts if
Sanders isn't the nominee will you vote
for Jill Stein of the Green Party for
president no I would not vote for Jill
Stein she's incredibly anti-israeli in a
way that to me is completely unhinged
and i would i would not vote from jill
stein I mean Bernie Sanders and jill
stein are very very close on a lot of
issues we analyze this when we
interviewed her and I vote for Hillary
Clinton over jill stein particularly
because of that view on Israel that I
think of hers is just so so disconnected
from reality
I think just regardless of her policies
unfortunately we don't really like the
two-party system but what kind of stuck
in it anyway I don't think you can
slowly move out of the two-party system
just by voting for third-party
candidates I think there has to be some
legislation passed that basically
quashes it immediately or at least
attempts to so voting for her would
probably be pointless I hate to say it
but I do feel that way and would and
would probably give an edge the
Republicans did in Massachusetts where
the Democratic candidate is going to win
the Green Party could qualify next
election for federal funding the thing
is if next time they're going to run
jill stein again i'm not interested in
her really being a viable candidate so i
don't i think for that reason I probably
wouldn't do it in ya rabi who was the
last green party candidate that you
would have thrown your support my
alternator Green Party I mean Ralph
Nader was a great candidate ended up
playing spoiler but i did a ralph nader
i think was was a solid candidate yeah i
think generally across most of the
elections that we can remember you know
there just really wasn't anyone not
memorable not recently i mean i think
that's part of the problem i totally
agree with you the two-party system is
just completely bogus in a disaster but
for me personally voting for Jill Stein
is not the logical thing for me to do so
no I will not be voting for Jill Stein
no matter who the nominee is on the
Democratic side let's go to the next
question who do we have next Tyler J
what are look some of Louis's favorite
computer games PS i would love to play
games with louis well that's doable
louis i mean you're on a bunch of games
right yeah I i I'm kind of a solitary
gamer as they say I don't do much
multiplayer but you know quick recap of
my favorite games of all time at the
original XCOM for dos I still think is
one of the best games of all time
mechwarrior to memory two mercenaries
those were big ones big into really good
FPS games thief was one of my favorites
i love stealth games as of late i find
that it's harder for me to hold my
attention they forget to hold my
attention I find that I do need a decent
story and I like all the elements of
gameplay to be really well done
otherwise I get bored so recently I mean
I've been playing far cry 4 I just
started playing that long about 15 hours
in but that's pretty fun I want to play
Witcher 3 next that's that's very higher
my favorite games I guess are the
original XCOM still one of my favorite
games all of the Mario Brothers games I
love Tetris the grand grand theft auto
games I have always liked and Microsoft
Flight Simulator it's a very limited and
laying sort of combination in a sense
but I really don't do that much gaming
but if I do I'll usually pull out one of
those okay next question let's see who
we have next we are getting a lot of
great questions here Craig what why do
you think that Ted Cruz eligibility for
office is not getting more traction on
the form of Judge and have read all the
articles about this and I think there is
serious doubt about his eligibility yeah
we're wrapping up research on this with
on this angle the ted cruz eligibility
issue and we're going to have a video on
it the sort of controversy seems to be
around the definition of Natural Born
which in the research we've been doing
Louis and I know you've been reviewing
it in preparation for the video we're
producing the term natural-born has
never really been tested legally it's
never been defined fully and there's
very little mention of that term
actually in the founding document it's
just you're supposed to be a natural
born citizen the if you believed that
President Obama was not a natural born
citizen then it would be crazy crazily
hypocritical to believe that Ted Cruz is
a natural born citizen that being said
like like I said Louis it hasn't really
been explored legally and that's why
Donald Trump as craziest Trump is he is
suggesting Cruz go out and proactively
get a declaratory judgment from a core
about whether he qualifies as natural
born the the real question now seems to
be not so much his his eligibility based
on where he was born because if you were
born to an american citizen no matter
where you were born you are your
according to many legal experts
considered natural born it's that his
mother was on reportedly the voter rolls
in canada which would have meant she was
a canadian citizen which puts the whole
story in question the rebuttal to that
is that was a preliminary canadian voter
list she was never actually on the
canadian voter list we're hoping to
uncover some answers in the next couple
weeks before our video on this goes live
yeah I mean it's why is it not a bigger
issue regardless of the actual legal
stuff it's because he's a Republican
it's because right that's why it's not a
bigger issue that's why it's not getting
more coverage more attention is because
you don't have millions and millions of
Republicans pushing it I I don't know if
we should be pushing it you you think
there might be something to it and I
mean thus far it seems like the legal
precedent has been the same and that is
if that you are born to an american
citizen in a foreign country you are an
American citizen I mean that's that's
all we really say right now all right
great question we are starting to wind
down so we'll do some quick hits Lewis
and see how many more questions we can
get to hear so Matt let's see the next
one from christopher salerno always
great to hear from christopher in texas
lewis's former temporary or I guess
temporary former home louis where do you
get your material for your show for the
bonus show oh this is a good question i
don't think you really address this
louis
ok well there's there's a lot of places
for the bonus show I like to go to sites
like gizmodo the verge I know we haven't
had many texts stories lately but I'm
big into those and other sites you know
I sometimes have good things in those
departments of Technology and science
and of course when I'm just going
through my mail and doing general
facebooking and twittering and stuff
I'll see headlines I'll pick up on
things I'll follow them and see what
happens and as far as the other news
stories go I'm a big fan of BBC I'll
check out the huffington post from time
to time I don't know why maybe just for
some Abbott the BBC is a big one another
one I don't remember who mentioned this
one to me and they're probably in the
audience right now not really news but
there's a reddit subreddit called not
the onion the idea is that yes these
headlines are real these are real
stories and I know it sounds crazy but
it's not an onion article and it is it
is pretty funny and sometimes I will
gather material from there I via that
sum it up really i guess i'm sure i'm
forgetting front of the audience
increasingly as well sometimes i'll send
you stories oh yeah oh yeah yeah of
course that goes without saying there
are always people emailing me sending me
stories and I I love it I appreciate
that that is great don't stop really
thank you christopher we will keep
answering questions i'm ok going a few
minutes over here just to get a few more
questions answered richard is on Richard
I would love to answer a question from
you oh you're on right now I know what's
live hello oh hello yeah so a longtime
fan I don't have really a specific
question I wanted to get in on the Ted
Cruz debate about what he's a
natural-born citizen or not I actually
am an immigration officer I work for the
home security and one comment I would
make along those lines is that there is
a security concern because if you are a
citizen of another country you have to
basically renounce that citizenship in
order to be eligible to have a security
clearance so if you're president of the
United States of course that would be a
concern so I don't know if Ted Cruz
still holds the Canadian self-interest
as well as you insist around 18 months
ago he renounced the Canadian
citizenship I believe okay so that
really wouldn't be an issue so I go back
to the probably back to the natural
believe it would end it sin shut seems
to be like discussed that it's probably
a settled issue yeah are you of the mall
I mean it's not a settled issue based on
the research I've done in the sense that
it has never been tested and I know I
sound like Donald Trump here it's so
that I think is going to be the real
question what is that definition with
regard to eligibility for presidents so
very very interesting Richard thank you
for the wise input on this all right
let's take a couple more questions here
before we wrap up Adam Smith why are the
two of you so very defensive of lutein
infant male circumcision most of us
understand there are some rare
circumstances where this is necessary
but the overwhelming scientific
consensus that isn't bought and sold or
against it a lot of us would like you to
see you join us in this progressive
endeavor putting aside the crazy mobs
that are waiting waves on this issue
well I think I don't know that the
premise is right i mean when you say
most of us most i'm not sure who most of
us is i mean we we don't really take a
position beyond just reporting what the
medical community says on it and i know
Louis that the counter to that is oh
well the medical community is bought and
sold because they want to do
circumcisions or for whatever reason but
we basically have just reported that
that most recent analyses by medical
communities have been a parent's choice
not really something you have to do we
don't recommend doing it but the
benefits outweigh the risks and we just
sort of report that i know it has become
very very controversial among some
circles groups like the int activists
and I'm trying to remember the different
groups that have those names but yeah I
mean I think you know us being very
defensive i think might be a
mischaracterization we just sort of like
report what the medical community says
about it yeah I mean we kind of have to
defend ourselves from attacks after
report on what you know the pediatric
associations say and I believe our
reports came from American pediatric
associations I I'm not sure really what
information were getting on that from
Europe at the moment maybe their review
this was a combined effort but they have
said if you believe they're bought and
sold it doesn't really matter what they
say on what the same mindset is Dave
really I say that it's still okay to
leave it up to the parent evidence
suggests that the benefits outweigh the
risks and at least if you if you believe
the information from these pediatric
associations so I also am NOT of the
mindset that I would not compare it to
FGM I know a lot of people do that and I
think those are two separate things at
least as they are currently practiced
yeah so anyone else you get I mean I've
tried to have conversations with people
about those who feel very strongly and
they will say it is the same as FGM
that's it if you don't see it is the
same we don't even have common ground
enough to have a conversation about it
and the other one about parents deciding
there's this argument of well the child
has no say in the parent deciding which
of course holds true to any number of
decisions that are made and I've had
trouble even finding enough common
ground to have more of a conversation
with people about it because they
escalate so very quickly with a lot of
these comments so and then lastly every
time this comes up unanimously we get
emails from women saying that women
women prefer circumcision on men and of
course the counter to that is well if
they preferred men with one year should
men go and chop up one ear off just for
the sake of it I mention it only nearly
as a point of interest and nothing else
so hopefully that answer to Adam is
satisfactory I know it is not a
satisfactory answer to a lot of people
let's go here Connie Connie says
read on several alternative news sites
about top Tom cotton accepting a million
dollars from Israel to sabotage the Iran
nuclear deal haven't seen this covered
is it something you might cover yeah I
would look at that is I don't know
exactly what the date of that what
native that was I mean if it's my guess
is Benjamin Netanyahu has his hands on
that we are very anti Netanyahu and it
would not surprise me that would be sort
of the prime culprit in my mind that I
would think is a would be involved in
something like that and yeah Netanyahu
is not going to be a force for peace
whatsoever we will take a couple more
questions next question is from mike
bell what are your drinks of choice i
just saw luis take a swig of what looked
like a brandy louis are you drinking
over there this is talisker a nice
single malt scotch that's actually the
one Dave got me for my birthday so
that's what I'm enjoying right now I I
am big on the single-malt scotches and I
love Bourbons whiskey's of all kind
really really good whiskey and really
good beer those are my goats you lately
I've just been into like good vodka
vodka soda with lime and that's you know
what good vodka is Ida pet guess depends
on who you're talking to I also recently
got a bottle of fernet which is crazy
because being Argentinean you would
think I would have been a where of
fernet earlier because it's such a
popular after-dinner drink there so I
have that and you know I'm into like
craft cocktails I'm open to different
things bees knees as a cocktail I like
so there yeah let's see if we can fit
two more in here before five after the
hour ask the alligator says do you plan
on doing more long-form research
segments like the one on Reza I think
one on sam Harris would be great yes
first question or second question today
was about this specifically tomorrow we
are debuting a long-form piece on
undocumented immigration let's squeeze
it we can add to that we plan on doing
these regularly we have we have many
things in the works so there're more
coming the next question up on screen we
already have in the word
not only the immigration video tomorrow
we also have a video on the eligibility
of ted cruz coming up and we have a
video also coming up on the truth about
the gender pay gap which i think will be
very very controversial Paul McGinnis
Paul McGann is joining us are we going
to be able to see Paul let's see hmmm
not seeing Paul there all right in the
interest of time we will have to
continue without Paul because I want to
try to squeeze two more in Alex
ehrenfeld who do you think the vice
presidential choices will be for Sanders
or much less excitingly Clinton I was
talking with someone about this
yesterday louis i don't think Hillary
Clinton will have Bernie Sanders as her
running mate I don't think Bernie
Sanders would have Hillary Clinton as
his running mate but beyond that I
really don't know I'm not sure that I
see Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth Warren
would certainly not be Hillary Clinton's
running mate I don't see that as likely
maybe for Bernie Sanders I think that
generally when you have someone like
Bernie or Hillary that are considered
generally sort of northeastern Democrats
even though Hillary of course ties to
Arkansas I think the strategy is you get
a southern Democrat or Midwestern
Democrat that will appeal to a different
demographic yeah i think so i would love
course love to see Warren teaming up
with Bernie I think that would be
fantastic and I think that would work
wonders for for Bernie but that's if
she's even up for it and they are very
similar on many many issues it's
probably better to diversify a bit more
so we'll see but Warren ghoul I would
pick one night and you last question for
today who will it be it is an bryant do
you have any news on the rumor of
bloomberg running for president
independently yeah we reported on it
today what we know is that he would get
depending on who the other candidates
are he would get somewhere between eight
and thirteen percent support it looks
like and it's not clear whether he would
be more of a spoiler for the democratic
or republican candidate so i think there
is some danger to michael bloomberg
running although if he were the
Republican nominee he would be by far
the most
reasonable guy i mean a lifelong
Democrat very very in favor of gun
safety regulations etc so I think it is
just a matter of wait and see he said if
he ran he would put up to a billion
dollars of his own money into the race
and that could be pretty formidable yeah
we'll see if you really can buy
elections if he decides to to run it
through invest that much money all right
that is going to do it for tonight we
should do another one of these sooner
because I see that there are many many
unanswered questions but Louis you have
to leave people wanting more imagine if
we stayed on for six hours that wouldn't
be good I'm told by people who know
about this stuff that would be really
really bad so that will do it for
tonight tomorrow what a fantastic piece
on undocumented immigration that we will
be releasing and we will schedule
another one of these very soon thanks to
everybody for your support I will talk
to you soon Louis that Talisker good
luck with that we will talk to you later